bro I'm hungover I can't play today
throwing up before the game you know I
get it all out my sister's crazy yeah
it's so crazy because that was the best
game I ever had in that Bill Clinton
Portis was good man you got a Washington
legend hurricane great you grow playing
pool hey this is my first time you said
is your first time first time I was
practicing outside your rookie year with
the Denver Broncos take me through what
happened
rookie night oh it's most epic rookie
night of all the time right so al Wilson
Shannon Sharpe Paul Roth's Meath Brian
Griese
everybody came out and differed the
entire team party together sale is so
you got squat everybody was it it was
like man we're gonna have a wicked night
we got to do this right you know well
you get the vets out you know they're
gonna get him a bottle of champagne they
did it right what bottle champagne we
talking back then I think it was more
like mo it was big you know Ricky night
you're supposed to be reasonable on the
tab court lay our tab probably was 20
grand
what do you spend $20,000 on Ray goes
back then at 21 22 you would definitely
know him dark and clear be young y'all
you drinking anything you're just trying
to have a good time but Friday night
probably lasted till 5:00 a.m. Saturday
morning I ended up being sick on Sunday
what is sickening I was hungover I'm
sorry
so I was in worse condition from Sunday
then I was Friday or Saturday like it's
one of those bro I can't clean this game
and I'm getting ready to walk into coach
enemy office and as I walk to his office
Shannon Sharpe say oh what you doing man
I can't play he was like oh no like that
that's not a problem you still got to go
out and perform so I'm like what he's
like man don't do that go outside run it
out he was like come back in contrast
whirlpool is hot cold hot cold until you
feel better so I go outside and I'm
sprinting up and down the sidelines this
is before the game I'm running a hundred
yard Sprint's full-speed come back in
Berlin everywhere you know but I'm
starting to feel better you know I get
it all out my sister's crazy it's so
crazy because that was the best game I
ever had in the NFL I had 17 carries for
13 years against Arizona and I was
hungover like totally done that was in
2002 by mistake Ricky night right so now
your speed up
maybe 2006 this famous shot game the
hitting game what's your you teammates
you got yourself Santana Moss and Sean
Taylor in DC in Washington
we're playing Jacksonville Jaguars me
antennas sending them in the parking lot
so you know we get turned in the car I'm
like man I finna take another shot a
hinny in of course we tell something
like but we're gonna take a shot we got
to go out like we got to win this game
so me Sean in 10 we chose to take a shot
tennis score two touchdowns UK women
Sean had a crazy game I had a crazy game
another 100-yard game against one of the
better defenses in NFL how often do you
guys do this ritual it wasn't like this
is what we look forward to this is what
we did every week you know it was just
if we had one of those games like man I
got to go ball out Cheers
and we out
[Music]
and this ain't your first time bro
there's no way here this your first time
man learn it on the run
thanks for kicking it with us subscribe
to be our to check out more dope videos
like this one